my story begins when i was a young boy
you'll be comfy here in your mama's own
room i'd do anything for her to be here
right now
grandma was a tough lady with a big
heart
and little by little she brought me out
of my
sadness
i didn't know it but there was a dark
shadow looming nearby
[Music]
witches they're real
and they hate children welcome
what would you do if there were mice
learning all around us is so dead
i would call the exterminator you see
girls he would exterminate those brats
uh rats
we would exterminate the rats
i feared this was happening
[Music]
then here that means a test is coming
ladies i have a plan hundred
to transform a child into a mouse
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll never let you get away with your
filthy evil plot
who's gonna stop me doesn't matter who
you are
or what you look like as long as
somebody loves you
you wouldn't happen to be carrying
around a mouse
on your person now would you a mouse
why on earth would i be carrying around
a mouse
[Music]
you